companies are beginning to release their
coveted Superbowl commercials ahead of
the big game over the past decade the
average cost of a 30-second Superbowl ad
has increased by 87 percent the price
for a spot this year is five million
dollars one of the ads getting early
buzz is a lip sync battle between
Mountain Dew and Doritos it stars actors
Morgan Freeman and Peter Dinklage
Doritos blazed a bold new flavor that
brings the media reporter and
Advertising Age good morning good
morning why do they release these early
I guess so we can have this conversation
we're having now yeah they want to get
as much publicity for the ads as
possible as you said you know the prices
have just gone up it's cost five million
dollars for a 30-second spot in the ad
so they're they're really want to put as
much publicity behind these as possible
so they pre-release a lot of these and
the the theme there's been some
political ads is that something you're
expecting to see again this year or does
that turnout material you know getting
consumers kind of irritated yeah I think
most of the ads will be more
lighthearted and funny that a lot of the
advertisers are going to steer clear of
talking about politics or social issues
I think for the most part we're going to
see humor play out Groupon is coming
back for the first time since I think
you said 2011 they can thank Tiffany
Haddish for that great story yeah well
let's take a look at the adverts and
then you can tell us a backstory because
it's good when you use Groupon in your
neighborhood you're not only saving
money you're also supporting local
business I mean what kind of person
wouldn't want to support local business
I hate local business family-owned even
better shut it down when you save in
your neighborhood it feels so good it
didn't feel good for him now
I like that Tiffany Haddish I think a
lot of fun but the back story she was on
Jimmy Kimmel talking about how she used
a Groupon voucher to take Will and Jada
pinkett-smith to this louisiana tour and
it kind of just blew up it went viral
she's apparently a huge Groupon user and
they brought her on smartly no coz Will
and Jada guys thought it was going to be
a private trip so when they came and all
those people were there they said why
are all these people here and she said
it's Groupon and they said what is that
that's why I think it's genius that they
put them together Perry all right
Eminem's making a return to the Super
Bowl 3-year hiatus and starring Danny
DeVito let's take a look I've had three
people try to eat me today three ooh
Lucky Penny anyway sometimes I wish I
were human
[Music]
nobody want to eat me
[Music]
you dropped your Lucky Penny
and I look good you're still short and
bald how does that fit into the whole
theme of this year a family viewing that
could go many ways the theme is you get
hit by a football or a bus slapstick you
know I think they're really looking to
keep this light it's been a hard year
they don't want to lean into a lot of
the issues that we're talking about and
seeing in the news every day they want
to just keep it a fun conversation for
during the Super Bowl in the past
there's been a big gap between men ads
and women ads do you think given the
climate that things will be different
this year because I think most people
think of course more men watch football
than women well you would think that
last year was just under 49 percent
female watch the Super Bowl so there's a
huge huge female audience yet the ads
still are heavily skewed male both in
the context and the people that are
starring in the ads themselves you know
last year we took a look there were 61
men in featured roles and 23 women and
it doesn't look like that's going to
change much this year I like the point
that a lot of women watch football
absolutely important point to me
absolutely what's Budweiser doing this
year so Budweiser will actually be
promoting some of its philanthropic
efforts it's water it's bringing water
to areas hit by natural disasters so
instead of a commercial featuring the
Clydesdales which is what they typically
have done they are promoting their
philanthropic efforts but I like the
Clydesdales they will have a puppy good
morning we just found out that the
Clydesdales will actually be in a five
second bumper ad for a live feed of the
Clydesdales that you can then go watch
online so they're not getting rid of
them apparently entirely good good right
but who had to deliver that news to the
Kleins do you might have been a little
traumatic for them thank you very much
Dean yeah great to see you can forward
to Sunday